hi everyone Karen warden with film
courage the radio show and we just had a
very wild fun show with filmmaker Travis
leg and also our guest host Vinny wolf
and he's a comedian and also co-host of
bipolar nation here on la talk radio at
11am on channel one on Sundays but
something that came up during the show
that I guess maybe you weren't aware of
is that you were really the catalyst for
David and I the start film courage and I
guess you hadn't even been aware of that
um because you recommend it to a friend
of ours Gregor Collins um show called in
the can with Kip Brown and we actually
went on that show and then later became
hosts on la talk radio so knowing that
knowing that you had an impact um in in
people's lives at how does that resonate
with you it is oh it's great to hear
because sometimes here when you're in
this town you get a lot of rejections or
a lot of actually sometimes your voice
isn't Harry the one always a comedian or
an actor or performer always wants to
have themselves be heard and when you
think yourself the more and more people
walk by you in life either what it was
my what am I here for and I tell like
you have those looked out so if you know
you need a little bit of a pat on the
back and something and this was a rough
week and i gotta tell you to be honest
with it was amazing to hear that i might
have done something to spark something
your creative flow into in the deli talk
radio one of them was exciting sounds
and most people don't hear a little more
the dog whistle type thing is a sound of
an idea the fact that when let's say you
have a kid comes up to you and says
please yellow and blue make you tell
them green and they're like oh something
and there yeah there's a sound that you
hear when someone something positive is
going to be created and we we think in
this world that everything's been seen
that done that but to me I don't think
it's true and the fact of the matter is
that it the fact that I might have
helped somebody help that might help
someone create something that they
wanted to do in their process and make
the world a better place and you guys
paid it forward with a lot of people the
last two years my correct yeah to yes it
it made me feel like i'm not that i
actually am helping people on the way
which is the goal other than of course
projecting myself like a lot of the
selfish comedians so speak well and I
wondering too because you know being in
this town there's that fine line you
want to promote yourself but you don't
want to be obnoxious about it yeah um
how do you walk that line I mean how do
you how do you remain friendly and and
keep putting your message out there
without being like a used car salesman
yeah we we train people how I want to be
treated but I will say this i was
watching the apprentice one time of
Donald Trump was talking about sales and
the beauty but the beauty of that shows
that you get a chance to learn a very
valuable it's almost like a television
version of Dale Carnegie you know how to
win friends and influence people and you
see some sabotages and you'll see some
people working as a team but he had said
he goes there's a lot of people out
there that are much more talented than
Sinatra was or brenda was all that kind
of stuff but they don't know how to sell
themselves and I've struggled with that
because there's that part who wants to
just come out and say hi I'm Vinnie wolf
and and but one thing I learned is that
i learn where my role is somewhere like
if someone tells me if someone says I
want you to be on the show I have I want
to see what they need me to do on that
show I don't want to become the video
wolf show that's going to come in time
oh well you want to find out where your
helpful where is where are you and that
teamwork of that day but when it comes
to sales I just really put it out i have
an FTW t-shirt line I just you know
stand up and I actually um you know I
have a website and I tell people about
it and I Facebook and what have you but
I'm the way I walk through a room and
protect myself but mainly is is too I'm
contrary I don't know I don't do things
because I want people to like me I just
am Who I am but somewhere in between
there you
have some sense of respect decorum
when's the right time to say was on you
be that person when's the right time to
go Wayne once wrote lifetime with
someone else shine was humbling than me
is when I started doing I was doing a
background work for the studios and I
always would look up like I was I was
doing it moneyball of Brad Pitt I'm
sitting right next to bed for three days
all the girls whoo brick and I said you
know it's it's funny ninety-eight
percent of all communication is
nonverbal so on the big winner here
today bread as my way of saying you know
it's brad pitt's time to shine in this
particular moment I'm not here to steal
from Brad Pitt I'm here to accentuate
the scene but they're all yours going to
come a time where I'm on the other side
and then people don't look and say you
know I have to follow through because if
I'm in that scene let's see i'm like
yeah Brad Pitt when he when he does
Moneyball he is support yo it's not just
him doing it he is his performance his
respect for the crab all that kind of
stuff creates jobs for other people so
he has to know his lines he has to do
this do that I think that when it gets
to that point I had I had to be able to
deliver and and be ready and I think
once you hone your skills and you
actually learn both sides or empathy for
one another one person to another I
think that that's what helps and
sometimes from doing that kind of work
to doing this where I am a guest I'm not
it's not the video show I put myself in
the place of where do you guys need me
that's going to come to town with my
time with my time